buenas tardes
estoy aquí para hablar de brujas y de
brujería para contar para contarnos una
historia
una historia que es una historia
terrible
una historia terrible la de las brujas y
la brujería
esa historia que os quiero contar es
terrible en primer lugar porque trata de
mujeres terribles de mujeres horribles
mujeres viejas de rostro feo y de cuerpo
deformado
por eso la historia de la bruja y la
brujería es siempre también una historia
de la fealdad y de lo repugnante
esta historia terrible es en segundo
lugar una historia de mujeres horribles
acusadas de hacer cosas terribles
mujeres que vuelan por las noches que se
reúnen en asambleas los aquelarres
mujeres que hacen cosas terribles contra
el buen dios primero pero no solo
también hacen cosas terribles contra los
demás
contra las vecinas con de los vecinos
contra sus bienes
las brujas matan matan el ganado traen
el granizo que arruina las cosechas
de sangran a los niños llenan la aldea
de pulgas convierten los matrimonios en
estériles provocan los abortos roban los
penes y los esconden en nidos ocultos en
los árboles
además y esto resultará siempre decisivo
acuden al le rinden culto se
someten a él
a cambio el les ofrece sus
poderes por eso la historia de la bruja
y la historia de la brujería es siempre
también la historia del y la
historia del mal
esta historia terrible es en tercer
lugar una historia de consecuencias
terribles
una historia de mujeres perseguidas
juzgadas y castigadas una maquinaria que
se pone en marcha para aniquilar las
de que estamos hablando de un mínimo de
90.000 a 100.000 juicios celebrados
entre los años 1400 y 1700 y sobre todo
entre los años 1500 60 y 1630 estamos
hablando de miles y miles de mujeres
condenadas por el crimen de brujería y
sentenciadas a morir
estamos hablando de una maquinaria que
se pone en marcha en todas partes de la
cristiandad occidental tanto entre los
católicos del sur como entre los
protestantes del norte dando en europa
como las américas recordad los procesos
de salen en nueva inglaterra en el año
1692 que acaban con 20 ejecuciones
a esta persecución prolongada y a gran
escala
la llamamos la casa de brujas es el
equivalente del which grace inglés
es muy revelador me parece a mí que esta
casa de brujas es algo que no se produce
en ese mundo supuestamente oscuro
bárbaro y fanático que había sido la
edad media no
se produce en ese mundo de luz que se
dice el rasgo del renacimiento es muy
revelador muy que la historia de nuestro
mundo moderno se inicia con miles y
miles de víctimas inocentes
que hay en toda esta historia
hay en toda esa historia en primer lugar
unos protagonistas la brujería es una
historia de mujeres de mujeres malas
maléficas
cierto hay brujos pero su existencia
nunca nunca logra la relevancia de las
brujas nunca inspiran esos brujos lo que
inspiran las brujas
hemos de hablar por lo tanto de mujeres
de mujeres perseguidas de mujeres
condenadas por hombres sobre todo
son hombres los que justifican los que
denuncian los que juzgan los que
condenan y los que ejecutan son hombres
el maestro el doctor el legislador
el juez y el verdugo son hombres todos
ellos que se dicen buenos cristianos
hombres que actúan en nombre del bien
que es el bien cristiano que actúan
según la ley de dios el dios cristiano
el dios masculino
ahora bien no lo olvidemos se trata casi
siempre de dramas locales de pequeños
dramas los rencores entre vecinas y
vecinos por los motivos más diversos
una epidemia del ganado puede ser la
muerte de un hijo puede ser la
esterilidad de una esposa puede ser una
hostilidad usual en los mundos pre
modernos quienes son más acusadas las
acusadas de brujería quienes son las
brujas
son mujeres comunes y corrientes
muchas veces mujeres que no se pueden
defender mujeres pobres pobres y
solitarias mujeres viejas mujeres muchas
veces trastornadas y otras mujeres que
han sufrido durante años el desprecio la
humillación y la violencia de sus
maridos
todas ellas víctimas confesarían lo más
inverosímil una vez enfrentadas al juez
y sometidas de manera más o menos
sistemática a la tortura confesaran
cualquier crimen muchas llegan a ser
víctimas de reacciones histéricas por
parte de poblaciones de una aldea o de
una ciudad su ejecución
se convierte a menudo en un espectáculo
que satisface los morbos colectivos de
todas aquellas gentes que se definen
como buena gente
hay en esta historia
en segundo lugar unas fuerzas
unas fuerzas que ponen en marcha
y sostienen la caza de brujas que son
necesarias para la caza de brujas
fuerzas que son diversas de acuerdo
aunque hay dos que yo quisiera destacar
el odio el odio al otro el otro que no
es como yo el otro que está en las en
los márgenes el otro que es una mala
mujer la maléfica
las brujas son mujeres que personifican
el mal un mal que se cree como algo real
y presente algo que se encuentra en
todas partes un mal que es activo esto
es un esto es un mal que quiere hacer el
mal
un mal no lo olvidemos que además es
poderoso porque cuenta con el apoyo del
un al que las brujas
obedecen un que las domina y un
que las penetra sexualmente un
odio que se construye a partir de un
fanatismo religioso un odio que se ve
sancionado por la iglesia y el papado
pero también por los príncipes y también
por los municipios el odio a la maléfica
a la mala mujer se institucionaliza
la otra de las fuerzas de las que os
quiero hablar es el miedo el miedo al
otro al otro que es una mala mujer el
miedo que es por lo tanto un miedo
eminentemente masculino
este miedo masculino del que os hablo
enlaza con el miedo a lo que el hombre
percibe como el otro que es la mujer y
lo otro que es lo propio de la mujer
la mujer mantiene una relación con la
vida en cuanto que la edad y la guarda
esa relación se sostiene en un saber
acerca de la vida un saber que también
es un saber acerca de la salud tanto del
cuerpo como de la mente
este saber no es un saber del hombre
la mujer es quien nos cuida
cuando nadie lo hace ni nosotros mismos
eso es algo propio de todas las mujeres
de todas las mujeres siempre en todas
las sociedades humanas a lo largo de
toda la historia
estas mujeres de las que os hablo cuando
destacan se las califica como hechiceras
parteras comadronas nodrizas y también
porque no al cabo estás
como nos dice el tratado clásico sobre
la brujería titulado el martillo de
brujas del año 1400 86 escrito por dos
hermanos dominicos de alemania
nadie hace más daño a la fe católica que
las comadronas matan a niños e impiden
de diversas maneras la concepción en el
útero materno
desde el punto de vista del hombre desde
el punto de vista masculino este saber
femenino es un saber que tiene algo algo
mucho de secreto y de poderoso algo a lo
que se ve sometido el hombre por lo
tanto algo para él para el hombre
difícil de soportar porque es algo que
siempre cuestiona y cuestionar a su
pretendida y afirmada superioridad
un último punto
la bruja hoy
como historiador me interesa el pasado
pero también evidentemente me interesa
el presente
me interesa por lo tanto la bruja del
pasado y me interesa la bruja del
presente
la bruja del presente que está presente
difamado así desde que yo era pequeño y
en los cuentos donde aparecían
un presente que ha inventado una bruja
como metáfora
como metáfora de la opresión la opresión
de la mujer por el hombre que ha
inventado una bruja como símbolo de
resistencia y de redención femenina
no ha tenido poco éxito este invento ha
logrado convertir la bruja en un icono
pero único no siempre es mala historia
resulta de un abuso más que de un uso de
la historia
frente a esta mala historia el
historiador hace bien en llamar la
atención sobre la existencia de
discursos que se conectan con el
discurso de la bruja
rasgos propios de la bruja
si aparecen también en relación con
otros colectivos
por ejemplo los sodomitas por ejemplo
los gitanos
y notablemente los judíos
el judío comparte con la bruja comparte
por ejemplo el sombrero el sombrero tan
típico la nariz la nariz que le es tan
única tanto la bruja como al judío el
asesinato de inocentes y sobre todo el
de niños la alianza con el
la imagen que os he traído la imagen que
vemos
parece ser la imagen de una bruja no es
un actor
una judía una judía una imagen de la
alemania del siglo 18 las figuras los
personajes se confunden
y ello que nos enseña lo sencilla que la
comprensión de la casa de brujas
nos lleva a algo que está más allá de la
bruja y de la
a algo que tiene que ver con el mundo o
con un mundo en el que puede llegar a
dominar y hacerse colectivo el abuso y
el miedo el odio el resentimiento y la
humillación un mundo en el que puede
llegar a dominar la ausencia de la
compasión y la renuncia a la razón
un mundo en el que puede llegar a
combinarse todo esto para producir el
horror de miles y miles de víctimas
es la tarea importante tarea del
historiador señalar cómo se llega a
edificar lo que se ha definido como una
en haití
pero también es su tarea señalar la
posibilidad de hacer las cosas de otra
manera
de otra manera de establecer las
relaciones también las relaciones entre
hombres y mujeres
ni el miedo ni el odio sirven para ello
ni el miedo ni el odio cuando nos
gobiernan nos acercan al bien nos ayudan
a vivir nuestras diferencias
es el pulso de nuestra razón lo que nos
permite reconocer que es propio del ser
humano ser inhumano que es propio del
ser humano elegir entre hacer las cosas
mal y hacer las cosas bien
no sé qué opináis por mi parte
creo que siempre es recomendable optar
por el segundo o al menos intentar hacer
las cosas bien muchas gracias
[Aplausos]